hey all I know is it's good having
another brother moving to the
neighborhood and it's good to have you
over and I'll take that you will dig
this hey nice guitar collection
oh thanks Manny you want to hear
something yeah sure
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's read weddings
[Music]
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles and her eyes like the skies
of blue country music I grew up in Texas
you know so all right keep her safe from
the home is in the wrong side of town
where they're smoking the reefer and
acting like clowns keep that pretty
address from getting dirty in brown cuz
that's the American Way oh pretty racist
song racist against who of black people
black people men but I'm black well
keeping the redheaded girl away from the
homies on the wrong side of town homies
come on brother this is all kinds of
homies you know white homies Asian
homies homies are black no I think
you're making them black man I mean I
think that's your stuff you hear the
twang and then you assume that it's
racist but that's that's just what
country music is like look you're given
like this you like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take their beer by the
40 and their chicken deep-fried I think
we all know who were talking about the
only dark I like us when I turn off the
lacks the only hood I love this pony and
Wyatt and trust you if I can't see your
face
hey stop that that's racist what's what
what his race is about it the only hood
I love is pointy and white yeah man
let's talk about the Klan man the Ku
Klux Klan are you outside of your mind
that's traditional country music imagery
man like a pickup truck or sleeping
under the stars or your dog got killed
or your wife left you same thing I would
have been fine with any of those things
what is the difference between those
things and what is in the song they're
not racial hey you know what kindest say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like Farrakhan army right now oh my god
are you serious hey can you you know
kind do one more let me just do one more
dog I absolutely promise you that this
song it's not racist and it's impossible
for you to misinterpret it as such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
come on man hey Shh over here trying to
sing about a tire swing light off an
entire genre music the banjo strumming
and the drums are a banging let's get
the boys together and have ourselves a
hanging oh damn
now I see it now I see it
[Music]